[Applaudissements]
est officiellement lancée non le blanc
pour poursuivre notre lancée avec moi
c'est seulement le parti de
consommateurs qui peuvent remplacer
justin trudeau qui pouvait se battre
pour vous c'est le npd du m'accorder
leur confiance jamais honoré le regretté
[Musique]
le vote avait le plus de pouvoir cet
inventaire
les autres partis ont de bonnes raisons
d'avoir peur de nous les canadiens vont
faire un choix
quelle direction ils veulent prendre
pour le pays
[Applaudissements]
en direct du musée canadien de
l'histoire à gatineau le partenariat
canadien pour la production des débats
vous présente le débat des chefs 2019
voici patrice roy bonsoir bienvenue à ce
débat des chefs
madame messieurs les chefs bonsoir à
vous l'ordre de parole ont été chinés
ici on vous remercie d'ailleurs parfois
apparaître à l'écran le bon débat
[Musique]
premier thème environ 1000 témoigne jean
masson se termine ce soir d'un jeune
homme d'avoir une faveur aux questions
dans une ère où nous sommes de plus en
plus tout premiers à répondre justin
trudeau et de continuer de lutter contre
les changements climatiques
pam à chacun un peu mais je sais que
cette année j
cette question des premiers milliards de
litres en vous aidant notre chez vous
vous avez dit il alors premier trio
première convocation de dollars
en jumelant chef tim depuis kyoto celio
la taxe sur le carbone qui a dynamité de
plus montés en audio nous doit grimper
vous propose un chiffre de 100 sur le
pétrole cote qu'un prix sur la plaie de
bannir le plastique et la gravette fini
sa chute mais il faut arriver
chez 173 les promesses qui sont tous
super cette taxe m conax est une autre
c'était un gars du jeu souligne un des
grands défis que vous avez avec les
avec les mesures climatiques un panache
4 petites à 84 7 contre 4 8
la marque audi au tibet oignons d'avoir
de l'approbation pour les bons et les
mauvais projets n'a qu'à notre gamme est
encore marco arturo bris à l'imposer
écoutez c'est mieux que de du
deux cas de dengue et n'ont donc au
québec d'acceptabilité sociale monsieur
bernier chez me surprenez un sentiment
antisémite contre des boni de nos
contenus et nos sites
c'est pour ça les gens on n'échoue dans
le design n'est pas d'accord et d'autres
cadres du china glide car c'est dit
c'est dit c'est qu'il suffit monsieur
trudeau ont la même pression à ce qui
concerne les changements trimestre c'est
différent c'est que monsieur chez moi
imposer des tarifs et nous on dit
carte médicale tenace comme support des
3 p 100 % la lutte contre le changement
climatique dans un contexte national
ce qu'il faut dès maintenant
effectivement donc ont vu les problèmes
à 12h10 qu'un mode carwin taï do you
make a été écrit par et pour ce n'est
pas acceptable que deux je vous félicite
jusqu'ici vous voulez réduire les doses
à la thyroïde panama de l'économie
canadienne de djezzy certains
soutiennent que ça pourrait provoquer
beaucoup de pertes
[Musique]
ou troisième lien entre québec et lévis
du gouvernement tadjik jimmy climatique
une façon commandes de demander aux
opérateurs de faire tous chers pour tous
les canadiens y en a ce tour
nos émissions comment comprendre vos
dents mais jure-t-il volte-face sur les
projets de stades mais c'est clair nude
ou un futur d'utiliser pas au quine des
inondations négativement forte que
trudeau
vous avez premier en 2015
2 millions versé transit qui veulent
rien faire plutôt controversé la science
est vraiment alors on est déjà
max à notre deuxième temps final
madame une citoyenne marie saint jean
qui veut poser quelles mesures fiscales
minable d'abord parce que les
baby-boomers qui vont bible des
activités d'une entreprise un ensemble
de mesures que je vous invite à
consulter dans le détail la coût de la
vie est
pour le transport en commun et saint
jean pour votre question une des
premières choses que nous avons 75 %
[Musique]
dont la même position que tous les
autres bénéficient ce que vous voulez
entendre
le pays est endetté
on n'a pas acheté votre vote avec votre
argent mais si madame la question
[Musique]
jusqu'à notre époque
le numéro 10
jo tsonga
megan abbott estime de soi la mort on
travaille pour vous mieux encore il est
exact qu'on peut faire gagner quatre
matches à cognac a battu 4-2 d'oka
demande unanime des quatre conservateurs
quatre milliards de dettes sur la maison
comme question
trudeau et monsieur trudeau vous n'avez
on n'a toujours pas si elle disposait
micheline est complet la réalité c'est
qu'on avait tellement d' ambitieux comme
stoneham dans universelle qui n plus les
familles qu'il faut admettre catch au
lieu de ça j'ai juste donné que finissez
votre idée après que c'est un mensonge
vous avez menti
augmenter pour les plus riches jusqu'à
la fin des excuses non je regarde qu'ils
vont lui james murdoch a dit jeudi pour
terminer un trou d'eau ici et si on veut
relancer l'économie car j'en avais trop
ces entrepreneurs les entrepreneurs
beaucerons en beauce et entrepreneurs de
partout mais et nous avons vue pendant
dix ans sous monsieur rap et où vous
étiez tous les deux à faisait partie de
ce parti dans les infrastructures
d'énergie
dabi les gens peuvent aller voir dans
les gens dans les travailleurs dans le
jeu commence à vous poser parce que vous
merci merci merci c'est normal hélas une
bugatti du devoir bonsoir promis
d'abolir la gestion alors pour parler
plus en plus des moyens de gagner quoi
les familles qui vont économiser
merci la première amie jamais pour
qu'ils puissent garantir notre sécurité
chez moi les
yvo de boer
on n'était pas ce qu'ils cherchent
l'argent merci c'est l'alberta qui
attend le rapport
pourtant de battre le bas va arriver on
va aux citoyens nous avons pour débuter
ce thème citoyens attendent en français
vivre dans une minorité le cadet des
moyennes mais quand vous regardez notre
coach angie
cardy article m'a tuer
je montrais crêperie cette université et
j'ai protégé du snack ce qu'a dit chico
dit quasi stationnaire et deux moins
noir que vous avez ici des gens aux
cascades monaco 4 6 4 contre 4
je pense que je tenais
mais naughty dog à te di le bout du
tunnel
oui d'autres questionnements widgets
golden axe qui suit le match à dix
stades comme steacie chimie dont hoyaux
francophone internautes sur les langues
officielles au cou tandis que vous
viendrez tout système en gardant et
shy'm médecine par un moustique which is
now et je remercie surtout monsieur
grafe cannes uniquement oms regrette ces
mots tenir six premiers trios sur ce
thème de service ou citoyen monsieur
singh la cagole aniston gars et monsieur
blanchet visite mr sim vous pouvez
interagir bien sûr on a parlé je pense
qu'un moyen de manon oga culturel on a
bien quelques notes ni canio disparu
chez moi j'ai porté encore donc en fait
cette question ne soit même et surtout
dans notre style disney commune de
décisions qu'il fait en tout cas que nos
4 go et 4 go
[Musique]
nick hornby sow marqué par un déficit de
confiance
candide kaïno avec les mêmes droits
privilèges m kaka es ya dans ce cas de
douch comme tant d'autres et nous
croyons qu'à lyon et de tout ce qui
était au ritz qui boucle pendant ce
temps là les solutions ne se trouvent
pas leur relation promettent que des
snacks singh a notre lot et ont croisé
des données et dûment approuvés m
élémentaire nascar peu près tous les
partis se sont succédé à nantes au kenya
quatre dernières années on a vu des buts
[Musique]
parce que l'échéancier de le faire
voici tout ce que vous promettez hilton
heinze se troue douce a été lancée
toulouse l'avait promis à votre niveau
de guerre que tu as comme nous disons ou
taxer les géants du web
on va se dire des miettes qui reçoivent
des miettes jeu très doux rapide judo
revanche home a failli plus que je sais
recette là on est bons numéros
j'appelle patrice tchèque a brisé sa
responsabilité des contrôleurs
c'est blanc c'est l'ensemble des
entreprises qui pourraient être
encourues en signant ce type
[Musique]
politique étrangère et immigration
projet philippe bonsoir à vous les chefs
vous écoute mais 4 h au parc jusqu'à
2012 car go 4 go de disque masqué
jusqu'à ce que j'ai dit aux gars pour
construire les projets dits schnack ce
qu'a dit prêt dans ce n'est pas honnête
car mr nascar jimmie à nakta 14 je veux
dire le carnet 4 devant des hommes
fournis des tablettes ni au québec ni au
canada
can you
merci monsieur blanchet fine pour des
agriculteurs sujet sur l'oeuvre de la
circonscription de laval ait lieu parce
que de mauvaises cartes du snack sanoga
mouche je dis malheureusement de votre
baignoire diplomatique
chaque week end on cherche au tableau
d'affichage des choses dites que
financière de huawei mais oui et où
quand des tarifs douaniers
est ce que c'est un stade de ligue à qui
j'ai dit oui chee wah doo dudka rade se
prononcer que huawei
mais ce que dit on
quelque chose est fait les choses la
raison faisant la comparaison des
capacités fait que le négationniste wife
axé sur la sécurité la prospérité des
canadiens et j'aimerais faire remarquer
qu'une gamme et engadget nautique notre
ère la route les gens qui passent il
m'aimait tout cas c'est à nos frontières
sur leur chaise amateurs
la sécurité c'est ce que vous devriez
montana nos activités houillères tous
les attributs blanche et voici le
meilleur exemple c'est moins violent
autre trio autres titres mondiaux plus
tôt cette structure poursuit la
discussion sur les migrations pour une
catégorie d'immigrants est d'ailleurs
s'ils veulent travailler avec nous
[Musique]
l'opposition dont ka shing
mais irrégulière passe par l'intégrité
de notre problème l'accord des tiers
pays sûrs mais vous n'avez thomas pour
poser des questions
ce réchauffement climatique est un
problème annulés par les autres pays
[Musique]
contre le coût social avoir tout juste à
kiabi
dos à la tradition canadienne et des
procédés chimiques sur d'autres élites y
passent tous nos 6 km canada chine à
shanghai et de 12h au tibet dans deux
ans je qualifierais d'irresponsable
catholique dans le cadre des traités
d'extradition c'était un enjeu
d'extension l'ime chica
elle imposée par les américains qui
étaient pratiqués détaille personne de
kamina match du week end car cela me
[Musique]
donne à ses moignons identité éthique et
gouvernance nous lançons le thème avec
une question d'un pigeon déjà patrice
les chefs date n'a demandé votre
question
j'ai 63 ans j'ai l'impression d'aller
oui on l'avait les
les limites des droits et des questions
merci
d'avoir eu le courage de venir un pigeon
a dit m
nous poursuivons avec la première
confrontation à 3 suisses et les inciter
à voitures inutiles de deux questions
avoue 3 et je le ferai aux trois autres
fabien delahaye la chine
l'avenir est ce que je veux faire je
suis prêt pour la faire trop
terminer je peux vous dire que j'ai mis
dans le dernier débat
rigueur pour défendre les droits qu'ils
me respectent et occupé par la décision
du droit des femmes sujet et on va
poursuivre rester sur l'avortement on va
revenir et moins jeunes à l'unicité
mais je veux malgré vos convictions vos
convictions pro vie castanou richaud
monsieur blanchet je reviens je vais
tranquille c'est généreux accueil à la
reprise
la ballerine n'est gagné
[Musique]
maintenant justifier son prix cohérent
sur cet enjeu
vous êtes en train de vérifier comment
gagner si ce n'est que dix questions en
rafale
maintenant il a été beaucoup beaucoup
les entreprises ne soient pas des
contrats publics
4 mais surtout d'un gars une clause est
dit est dit est dit stark informatique a
compliqué encore gagnable donne à fond
nhk il ya un menu est ce que je veux
dire ce qu'elle a dit en fait oui de 10
10 mètres et émeraudes du chaos
d'habitude sonore quand je dis non
jusqu'à cordiaux
quand votre nom
il faudra c'est l'indépendance de notre
système judiciaire et justin trudeau a
dit oui aux stadiers karine nuire notre
système je dis oui à coude avec shionogi
quand tu m'as jamais changé m hattstatt
niort 4
misc donne acte voyons windows comme
tinto la communication car on est dans
une belle initiative et la transparence
du chef des tigres
bonjour des candidats dans certains cas
vous avez dû renvoyer
moi je connais des snacks chacun d'une
partir de maintenant est ce que vous
dites car tolérance des t notes
actuelles pour tourner garina d'akouédo
jugés racistes blancs kanaks a dit jeudi
je suis content qu'ils disent maintenant
en ligne n'importe quoi qu'il soit un
petit peu proches
des kits et de liberté de ton
pour nous elle est fondée sur des
principes le respect des politiques
alors le choix cette réaction s'explique
en tout cas l'avis qui devine plus cher
ou une pratique médicale qui va montrer
bien bouché 10 secondes pour savoir
parlement votre mais sur les chefs que
merci à vous chers tous condamnent
autonome hameau merci à tous
[Applaudissements]